I'm truly glad to be able to come to you
today and give you just an overview of
some good news about the virus and of
course we'll discuss the continued
challenges and there's lots of bad news
so I'm not pretending it doesn't exist
but I want to give everybody some
updates that will give us some hope that
we're starting to move in the right
direction despite the obvious challenges
and and unconscionable death that still
are ahead of us so first of all the IH
Emmy model which is one of the top
models currently being monitored and
updated daily has moved the peak in
terms of deaths in the United States up
from April 16th to April 12th that's now
just four days away the peak day
previously was expected to have three
thousand deaths in one day in the United
States that number has dropped up by
almost a third to 2,200 still horrifying
but one-third lower than it was expected
to be now importantly the peak is not
really a single day it's more of a
plateau and that plateau is expected to
run from today we are essentially in
that peak plateau right now from today
until close to the end of the month but
the latest prediction is that deaths
will start to decline in the United
States just four days from now roughly
the peak is going to come on a different
day in different states California New
York Massachusetts other places but that
is in general good news we are closer to
getting over the hump than we previously
believed number two another bit of good
news once the data from the last few
days was added to the model the expected
death toll of this first wave of
coronavirus has dropped to 60,000 now
that's a crazy number of people but last
week the model predicted 93 thousand
deaths in the first wave in the US
earlier this week the model predicted
82,000 that number has now dropped an
additional sort of 27 ish percent to
60,000 deaths a terrible number but a
reduction of almost 50
and since the or 35-ish 3540 percent
since the prediction was 93,000 now why
do I keep saying the first wave really
important to understand this some models
have a death toll prediction that is for
what are expected to be three waves of
infection this model is looking just
that the first wave right now doctors
and scientists believe we are currently
in wave one we will fall off of that
wave in May June July in the fall there
will be another peak which is wave two
and then in 2021 there would be a third
wave which is wave three hopefully by
then we would be well prepared to really
mitigate but that remains to be seen
this wave may end up with a far lower
death toll than we thought which would
be because of what we are doing I'll get
to that in a moment one other bit of
good news Ave again I told you about Ave
again weeks ago maybe a month ago it's
one of the possible treatments that's
being explored for coronavirus we are
now starting a clinical trial of a began
Japanese drug right here in Boston Trump
won't stop talking about chloroquine
chloroquine has some promise but recent
studies are not super auspicious I
previously told you about a began it is
showing promise and it's going to be
tested in Boston across a few hospitals
another bit of really good news is that
New York hospitals have been starting to
discharge more patients than are being
that are then are having intakes that
are being brought in over the last few
days New York is a huge hot spot right
now 35 percent of all official cases in
the country are in New York State if you
include New Jersey New York New Jersey
have 47 percent of all of the official
cases it's a very good sign that things
are starting to level out there other
states have to keep it up in terms of
distancing now remember anytime that
things look better than expected a whole
bunch of people will say we told you you
were overreacting we can stop the social
distancing this is a virus it spreads
virally that's where the word comes from
if what you are doing works it should
feel
like you overreacted if you're doing the
right thing it should feel like you're
doing too much for the level of spread
because you have to be ahead of the
curve anti-vaxxers will often say we
don't really need vaccines because
measles is so rare a lot of these
conditions are so rare they are rare
because of the success of the vaccines
if we reduce deaths as the model
suggests we are doing it's because we
were staying home and closing things
down not despite it it's still going to
be tough we currently have about 13,000
deaths in the u.s. if we believe the
model and we will end up somewhere just
under sixty one thousand what that means
is that 80% of the death is ahead of us
mostly in the next four to six weeks
this is really tough let's stay in this
keep pushing on treatment keep moving
the vaccine forward keep being
responsible and by the end of the week
I'll be able to further update you about
where the numbers are check this out the
first 500 people who see this video and
go to david pakman.com slash skill will
get a premium membership to Skillshare
for two months completely free skill
shares the online learning community
with thousands of classes on almost
anything you can imagine always taught
by experts they have classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and much
more I recently took a very interesting
class called simple productivity how to
accomplish more with less and got a
bunch of great personal productivity
tips out of it we should allow ourselves
a little time every week to either get
creative keep your brain sharp learn
something new it's great for mental
health and almost all the classes are
under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two home
giving you access to every class
Skillshare offers check it out I put the
link right underneath this video